so you want to start watching one piece
huh
i can't say i blame you in just about
any comment section around the world
there's bound to be a one-piece fan
breathing down your neck telling you to
watch it if you haven't already
and i'm certainly one of them over the
years i have successfully converted a
number of my friends who were once the
typical
it's too long type people into some of
the biggest fans i now know
i mean who wouldn't love to watch 1000
episodes of a stretchy pirate's search
for treasure
doesn't that plot synopsis sound like a
masterpiece already
as an anime watcher whether you've just
begun or have descended into the depths
of webdumb for years now
for healthy skin and long life which i'm
sure you all need
you should just accept that one piece is
never an impossibility
but instead an inevitability the boss
battle that you dread to face but once
you finish
you realize that it was easily one of
your favorites in the entire game
though there are lows and highs on the
journey today i'm here to do a little
bit of convincing and give you the many
reasons to watch one piece
the absolute behemoth of an anime or if
you've already fully committed and are
ready to begin hoisting the sales
tell you my favorite parts of what will
be the most memorable months of binge
watching you will
ever experience truly i still reminisce
of the three months in 2017 when i
watched all
of one piece up to around episode 770
the current one at the time
when i slept eight bled cried sweated
and
one piece and i'm sure you'll do the
same
and love it the whole way through and
here i'll take a quick side note because
although this video
is entirely about watching one piece in
no way do i mean to equate watching one
piece
to reading the manga nor will i say if
either is objectively better
i'll leave that up to the comments of an
inevitable group of salty redditors or
manga supremacists
both are entirely different experiences
and people have different preferences
for what they want
and as someone who watched one piece for
many a month and enjoyed hundreds of
episodes
including filler yes you heard that
right i did watch the filler
and as someone who has now read for many
years i will say that
you will likely enjoy both and with the
anime it will be a great
journey i'm sure as long as you're
willing to bear through the occasional
pitfall of any long-running shonen
and you're not an extremely uptight
manga fan that is but that is where i
will stop with the negatives because
this video is of course
all about what you will love about one
piece spoiler free
with the occasional vague reference to
arcs and moments that you won't even
understand if you haven't seen the
series so don't worry about it
or if you have already seen it instead
of informing you of what you'll love
about one piece
i'll take you on a blast to the past and
remind you of all the things
that truly made it into the adventure of
a lifetime
[Music]
and the adventure of a lifetime can only
take place in a masterfully crafted
world that holds it
which through its many seas land islands
sky islands and underwater islands
one piece does create with some of the
best world building in anime
a world where anything feels possible
where the sense of adventure truly seeps
out from every corner in crevice
and where this 98 of anime culture
corner viewers are actually subscribed
please subscribe one piece begins as a
very small
story we follow luffy on his small
wooden boat in the east blue one of the
many
small oceans of the one piece world he
has no connections no reputation to his
name
and slowly but surely we slowly garner
more crewmates as we learn the real
scope of the world more so than any
other long long-running shonen series
one piece is all about growth and moving
on
which makes sense considering the story
is about pirates setting sail and
exploring the world in search of a great
treasure
and because the story in essence follows
our crew just island hopping and finding
new
opportunities each island they stop on
is memorable
and distinguishable in its own way in
the 900
something nearly 1 000 episode run of
one piece so far
no island has felt similar to the one
before it
drum island and its snowy mountain tops
dress rosa and its dense
tropical forest and its caribbean town
alabasta's scorching deserts
the world of one piece is incredibly
diverse in climate and setting of
every island luffy and his crew steps
foot on
but also and more importantly in the
characters introduced in
each and the characters of one piece are
arguably the best part of the entire
series
granted the same can be said for most
shonen of this type
naruto would be nothing without the
hidden leaf shinobi and the incredible
villains like payne and toby
nor would bleach be much without the
devious eisen and ichigo
or i mean i mean dripago my bad but what
distinguishes one piece especially is
not just the sheer
size of the cast of characters but how
well fleshed out
and interesting nearly all of them are
the main crew of course receive their
own stories and character development
almost all of them have tragic tales
before joining the crew
often a story that has made them
naturally opposed to joining a team
actually nami was raised as a lone wolf
among a devious group of villains
trusting no one the same can be said for
sanji
and robin and frankie too but somehow
this
incredibly diverse and strange group of
characters
who have grown up so tragically opposed
to companionship
have been brought together against all
odds by luffy
the captain of this crew luffy's
charisma and will to do
anything and everything for his friends
outclasses just about
any other anime character you can
compare him to
and in a world where the old generation
pushes against him and fellow pirates
looking for the one piece clash with the
crew
where you must survive against all the
competition and all the odds
luffy shines as a symbol of rebellion
and independence
and freedom on the open seas
luffy's moments of defending and
fighting for his crew are some of the
most epic
in all of anime i'm sure if you looked
up luffy epic moment montage on youtube
you find some amazing
amvs that would surely send chills down
your spine
but the moments aren't just limited to
luffy either
zorro stand in thriller bark usopp
saving shot in dressrosa
robins yell atop the tower of any's
lobby
and expanding even further beyond just
our crew
as well alkiji arriving to stop
doflamingo
trafalgar splitting an entire island in
half
if you haven't watched the show you
won't get what i'm saying
but if you do watch it i'm sure you will
instantly recognize
all of these moments and remember just
how awesome they were
the list goes on and on because one
piece gives every character their moment
to shine and show off
minor characters who you never thought
of even after they disappeared in one
arc
will reappear in a moment's notice in a
great piece of poetic storytelling by
oda
and some of the initially lamest
characters will grow into
possibly one of your favorites yes i am
talking about kobe in both of those
scenarios
there are allies who side with luffy
after witnessing his charisma
and want to do good for the world and
enemies who would do
anything to see him dead and those with
a purpose
entirely separate from his and this
ambiguity of goals of characters in one
piece
people who are trying to achieve
completely different things on the vast
ocean
is one of its best parts i recommend
watching this video in the top corner if
you want a bit more depth into that
topic
but of course what are good characters
great moments
without a great ost to accompany them
a must of any one of the big three anime
is an
iconic soundtrack and i personally
believe that one piece
naruto and bleach all have arguably
equally
unrivalled osts this is one aspect at
the very least that i must give to all
of them from
sorrow and sadness in naruto
[Music]
to eisen's beautiful orchestral and
demonic theme in bleach
to the many in one piece that i'm sure
are playing right now in the background
of this very video
and what one piece excels in soundtrack
wise as it does with both characters and
the world itself what i mentioned before
is truly the variety after watching the
entirety of one piece
every fan surely has a gaping hole in
their heart
but once you hear that music whether it
is emotional
or adventurous or epic you are always
reminded of the good old days and
adventures of luffy and his crew
i haven't watched the anime in years but
every time i hear these songs i am
reminded of the past
the nostalgia i have for one piece or
any one of the big three for that matter
is truly one of the best gifts that
anime has ever given to me
there is always at least one iconic song
for just about every mood you can have
not to mention many of the openings are
among anime's most iconic of course
the very first opening of one piece
always makes me feel like a little kid
again
and the water 7 opening gives me warm
fuzzy feelings in my chest that
i can't really describe nor do i really
want to
however it's very possible you might go
through all of one piece
without listening to any one opening
more than even a single time
and i wouldn't even blame you actually
not because they're bad in fact it's the
opposite most are amazing
but you might not watch any of them
because of the curse
any and all one piece watchers
experience
the curse of binge watching
[Music]
because among the many anime i have ever
watched one piece is surely the most
bingeable of them all
everyone complains about how long one
piece is but you come to realize
that once you begin one piece it does
not feel that long
because you'll find yourself watching
episode upon episode
every single day to the point where you
see the sun set and rise
twice over in what felt like the short
time you've been watching
luffy just beat up another pirate you'll
blink your eyes and find that 40
episodes have passed
at some point in one piece around
halfway through the show maybe
including opening ending and the recap
of the arc thus far
episodes can be as short as 17 to 18
minutes which is
very dangerous and by dangerous i mean
very tempting to finish each episode one
after another because you think what's
the harm it's just another 18 minutes
and that 18 minutes turns into an entire
day of watching one piece
man i miss those days a feat that i
always keep in my little book
is the day that i watched 46 episodes of
one of one piece's best arcs marine ford
in
a single day are you thinking now no i
can't do that much
i'm not that much of a binger if you
aren't already if you are thinking those
things
one piece will do this to you embrace it
enjoy it
because it doesn't get much more binge
worthy than one piece
if there's one show you should binge or
that you have to
it's one piece with 18 minute episodes
it's almost
begging you to binge watch it
and now after what has probably been
over 10 to 15 minutes of non-stop praise
for one piece you're thinking
well what's the bad part then what's the
catch
well there is none
i'm joking of course as there are
certain pitfalls that one piece falls to
one piece is actually surprisingly good
about keeping filler to a minimum
at only 10 of the total showtime being
filler
especially notable considering just how
long of a show it is
i mean look at naruto and bleach
but the reason filler is so small is
partially due to the pacing of the show
especially post time skip one piece
which
takes its time with these arcs to say
the least
granted the arcs are long even in the
manga and a lot happens
but yeah it does get stretched out
sometimes
[Music]
plus animation does have its weak points
something that
actually people can't really complain
about anymore simply because of how
amazing
wano the recent one-piece arc has done
at completely redesigning the anime
visually and doing it
consistently i mean just look at this it
looks like a movie
so yes there are parts that you might
struggle to get through when binging
through one piece
i won't deny it i'm not a blind idiot
i'd like to think i know what i'm
talking about
i even took a week-long break during the
punk hazard arc in the midst of my prime
binging days
because i think my body hit the complete
limits of the
feeble human frame at that point and
needed a recharge that
only god eichiro oda himself could cure
but i firmly believe that the journey
that one piece takes you on in this
anime
is one that even if it has its ups and
downs
will leave you with countless memories
and moments
you can and will never forget
the kinds of scenes you want to show to
your kids when you get older
and you're watching it together because
the series is still not over when you're
an old man
whether it's because the scenes require
a whole box of tissues just to get
through without tears completely
blinding you
or because they are so unbelievably
hyped that you momentarily forget that
you're just watching a stretchy pirate
fight on a screen
one piece is the adventure of a lifetime
not just for luffy and his crew but for
the viewer as well
for you and me and everyone else
and to return to the question posed in
the title of this video
so now you want to watch one piece
i might just start re-watching right now
let's go baby
you